للسقي مكانه كبيره واهتمام بالغ ومحبه
عظيمه وقدر كبير في قلوب عشاقه الكفر
وخاصه الشعراء الذين تجمعهم به علاقه
ازليه منذ القدم فالصقوا يرمز للرجوله
والشجاعه والشهامه والنخوه والانسان الشام
احرى بان يكون شاب هلا
ويبدا الموسم السنوي للصغار في سبتمبر
وينتهي مع شهر فبراير حيث يجهز الصقارن
الشراك لصيده
من 20/9 بيبتدي تنصيب الحمام بنجيب الحمام
بنعد عليه شروكه اللي هي المخصصه للمصايد
يعني بيجيب حمامه وبحط عليها السلام اللي
هو الشرك بنبتدي نحط الحمامات بعد
المسافات مثلا 300 400 متر من بعض جنب
المخيم
صحراويه كامله
من عند ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
ولان الصقر طائر حاد الذكاء يحتاج اصطياده
تخطيطا من السقار فيتعون الصقر عبر
طريقتين اولهما طريقه الوكريه التي يدعى
فيها الصقر بفريسه تثير لعابه فيضع له
السمان او اليمام او الحمام
فرائسه تعجب الملك في عليائه كي ينقض
عليها وبعد الانقضاض يكون ريش الفريسه في
خيه تقع فيها قدم الصقر
فاحنا فاحنا نجيبه السمان ده اول نعمل له
الشرك
دي عباره عن خياط كده يجي الصقر مسكه اول
ما يبدا ياكل يذبح يذبح الصقر الاول
يتحرك مع الحركه